last night defense secretary Jim mattis
approved using Defense Department money
to pay for as many as 4,000 National
Guard soldiers for border security
missions president Trump's decision to
call for National Guard troops has Texas
and Arizona deploying 400 members to the
us-mexico border by next week mr. Trump
says the military will fight drug
trafficking and illegal immigration
until progress is made on his proposed
border wall which has mostly stalled in
Congress President Trump is standing by
embattled environmental protection
agency chief Scott Pruitt Pruitt is
fighting calls for his ouster over
alleged financial and ethical missteps
new details show that Pruitt sharply
increased spending for security and
travel arrangements
the EPA assistant inspector general says
Pruitt took those actions because he has
faced an unprecedented number of death
threats against him and his family for a
look at these and other developments we
turned the Gabriel da DeBenedetti sorry
Gabe who's just started his new position
as national correspondent at New York
Magazine Gabe good morning
congratulations thanks very much let's
start with the latest rounds of
sanctions which are some of the toughest
yet against Russia yeah absolutely
the president has imposed these new
sanctions but really the president is
the person who has been talking happiest
about Russia while the rest of
Washington has been trying to crack down
these are sanctions that we've expected
in some form or another for a long time
after the Senate passed the sanctions
program last year but this is really
aimed at cracking down on folks who are
very close to Vladimir Putin we'll see
what happens next here but obviously a
lot of people within the administration
are saying it's time to actually talk
tough and really crack down on these
folks for their financial misdeeds you
talk about what happens next we're gonna
see a national - new National Security
Advisor John Bolton take over next week
how will his thoughts on Russia shape
what is next well it's a great question
because we don't really know what he's
going to be saying to the president
publicly at least John Bolton has been
pretty much a hawk on Russia really
saying it's time to crack down on
Vladimir Putin but of course president
Trump has kind of fluctuated and we're
how he feels about Putin publicly at
least so it really remains to be seen
what we do know is that the president
likes to listen to his advisers quite a
lot so you know Bolton will retry to be
the last person in the room when it
comes to issues of Russia
and we may see a little bit of a change
of tack but no promises okay we were
just talking with Jill Schlesinger about
about the but the potential of a trade
war with China obviously and the in the
impact that's had on the markets
President Trump came into office with
significant support in the business
community is this a roading that in any
way do you think well that remains to be
seen obviously stocks have fallen quite
a bit and there is a lot of fear of a
trade war there's a reason that people
say nobody wins a trade war and
obviously with escalating tensions in
the United States and China and a number
of our other major trade partners people
in the business community are certainly
extremely wary we haven't yet seen
people pull the alarm yet ring the alarm
say to the president it's time to cut
this out because he's essentially said
I'm not going to cut this out no matter
what you say this is what I campaigned
on what about though going forward to
the midterm elections and that concern
obviously we don't know whether this
will escalate to a trade war and that
impact is is definitely on those states
that had supported him so much yes
absolutely and a lot of those states
especially farm states in the Midwest
are states that also have big races
coming up in the midterm so you do have
Republicans who are very concerned about
this talking to folks on Capitol Hill
over the last week a lot of them are
saying we're not sure that the president
really understands the impact that this
could have if China does retaliate on
soybeans and things like that for
example you had senator Ben Sasse from
Nebraska senator Joni Ernst from Iowa to
Republicans who have sometimes supported
the president sometimes not said things
like listen this is not the right way to
go about doing this it's going to cost
us a lot of support I'm sorry's and say
we've also heard from Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell has already
sounded the alarm yes absolutely and you
have leaders across the political
spectrum of the Republican Party who are
now fully saying listen these midterms
are not going to be good for us as a
Republican party we need to wake up and
pay attention and try and change course
you had Scott Walker the Governor of
Wisconsin who himself is up for
re-election
saying this over the last few months
finally getting people in DC to pay
attention the question is okay once they
start paying attention what can they do
about it mm-hmm
and on Thursday as we reported the
president said he'd like members of the
National Guard sent to the Mexican
border this is something that he also
has campaigned on and something his
basis is adamant about isn't it yeah if
we want to look at this politically this
is where the president feels most
comfortable you know over the last two
years one that we
no three years really he loves talking
about illegal immigration loves talking
about the wall he knows that a large
portion of his base is behind him on
this
but all this does obscure the reality
that the daka conversation on Capitol
Hill has gone nowhere we're not anywhere
near to having a real wall in terms of
major legislation on that so a lot of
this is tough talk
all right gave DeBenedetti thanks so
much for being with us this morning
thank you tomorrow morning on Face the
Nation here on CBS Margaret Brennan will
speak with Treasury secretary Steve
minuchin